how are you lookin rougher on the edges
then we're looking like our true selves
no hi my name is Chris let me know you
know your life is different now I went
down a wormhole of mikey or glam and
gore
it was amazing makeup artists videos
where she made herself into like this
pastel goth and as she made herself into
like 2000 version of herself and they
were so fun to watch and she's obviously
a professional makeup artist so she was
very good at it and I thought you know I
just turned myself into my dog what's
the next obvious transformation the
iconic denim dress duo that was Britney
Spears and Justin Timberlake in 2001 at
the American Music Awards what's better
than wearing a denim dress making it at
home on video for the internet plus I
went on Twitter and asked you guys for
inspiration of your favorite like 90 /
2000s look and so many of you recognize
this that I decided denim in denim bad
Adam it down on demand and I'm good I'm
in bitumen I spot a lot of denim but
today I'm gonna try and create friend
nice versus 2001 American Music Awards
denim iconic look I cannot think of a
better red carpet outfit than that where
does my t-shirt stop in the denim began
I'm also gonna actually try oh they were
so young and so poorly influenced by the
people around them precious a lot of you
watching this video that weren't even
born when this happened people were
making mistakes and order Occulus
statements forever
Shh ton of denim from the craft store
and when I was buying it the very lovely
woman that was helping me buy it was
like oh what are you planning on making
and I was like a bodice shirt thing and
I just need a lot of material I know I'm
probably gonna screw it up so she's like
oh that's nice
it knew she knew I was lying a girl my
age doesn't walk into joins fabrics and
buying this much denim fabric without
them knowing that I'm trying to make a
Britney Spears denim dress here we are
I have all kind of
rhinestones I'm even gonna attempt to
make this goddamn denim matching purse
so get ready
I've never made a denim dress before
shocking I know
guess what my Marvel superhero name is
denim like Benham okay oh here we go oh
we did it
goddamned it's like if they did the
musical Rent at stagecoach give me a
market piece also Britney Spears
Instagram highly recommend if you're not
be following it's one of the best
goddamn grams this seems already wrong
but there's nothing wrong about this
look what do you think her stylist said
to her when they both tried this on do
you think she walked into her stylist
house or apartment or office of the
sounds like I've got the best idea real
housewife means Nashville Project Runway
project cute I'm not gonna do a ton of
talking about how she get it to stay oh
just gonna be bad you're just gonna tie
it in the back and I kept on to excess
off the bottom that's a pleasant ASMR
sound
what's gym guns cover of workbench make
a workbench okay where we got other than
my pit stains because I'm sweating so
much cuz I'm nervous about doing this
bad boy so about the contrasting
patchwork you really want this dress to
look like Joey Fatone hair during the
height of NSYNC just kind of patchy Oh
think about it cared about being patient
I could really make this month like
really good but I don't know more iconic
piece of fashion always it's good when
it's this open in the back one of the
genius things about this look is that
the subtlety is about one being the
matching denim clutch that she is
holding which we're gonna try and make
right now I've ever made a clutch oh
hell no but we got plenty of denim
leftover taco coming in clutch let's
trace another taco fold that over and
glue that part down if Britney sir isn't
Justin Timberlake like I got him
pregnant this money that would make
Justin in a denim daddy that's a thing
right
I want to glue these back-to-back and
then turn it inside out Wow well this
goes down I'm gonna heat things up with
a plug for one of my favorite companies
audible you guys know that I have been
working with audible for ever both of my
books are available audiobooks on
audible if you haven't heard about them
let me know how that rock is that you're
living under given a match selection of
not only audiobooks but now shows news
podcasts etc eccentrics head oh they're
just constantly expanding plus they make
it super easy for you to switch devices
if you're in between listening something
you can go from listening on your phone
in your car to your echo when you get
home it just makes it very seamless plus
they have speed control so you can
listen faster slower depending on how
much attention you're giving to it and
any audiobooks that you get are yours to
keep it's not like a rental you you own
it now Plus this is extra fitting unlike
what this dress will be because mamrie
Hart
my best friend who actually I went to
see Britney Spears this show in Vegas
with has her new book I've got this one
available in audiobook form on audible
and you can get your first audiobook or
beat with audible.com slash race
audible.com so grace my name or you can
text grace Tracy 500 500 and now back to
what is shaping up to be a bad decision
here we go now we turned our taco purse
inside out uh that's kind of a clutch a
whole top of hers is super rhinestone I
bought a ton of rhinestones I'm gonna do
some detail work
[Music]
got a silver chain from an old thing
that I had so more hot glue that set
this is so stressful and I already feel
like this is not worth it at all
whatsoever but hey we're doing it yeah
so Britney's other major accessories
other than her dazzling smile and
personality and loose grip on her own
reality is obviously the completely
rhinestone choker and matching bracelet
and the belt that I think my stepmom
bought at a chicos once I think I found
this headband that I thought could be a
choker if I just put like more of these
rhinestones on it as we all know now is
a very easy fun activity to do what is
the point of it I must mean Brooks is
here hi rugs I'm making a video can you
guess what I'm doing but don't look at
this hey some way you see on this table
right here what do you think I'm doing I
already know you're doing you're
creating many foods like well this is
definitely a Brittany iconic 2001
Brittany Dustin I'm dreamer choker yeah
so your eyes only prize okay all my
accessories but beautifully beautifully
handmade beautiful accessories are done
ish for now now it's time to get the
makeup look as best we can so her makeup
for this look isn't that ridiculous
very thin eyebrows lob bronzer let's do
it I see some Baker eyebrows much more
muted much more like they came to the
party but they don't really want to be
the just me at every party oh she's got
blue eye shadow - oh man we're gonna
really go
I usually something awesome with like a
darker brown but her eyebrows look
orange use some of these colors or
something and I can get out of it well
thank you
there we go XS we got some blue
eyeshadow to do and some weight
highlighting around the eyes now I need
blue interstellar palette that sort of
has silvery blue this chair is a dirty
brush now I need some black don't think
she's wearing fake eyelashes but I can't
tell so I'm just gonna put some this is
now just becoming what I look like when
I went to prom oh let's do it kind of I
think our makeup look it's kind of all
there so let's put the whole goddamn
thing together see what happens here we
go
it's basically identical and I'm really
proud of myself for spending you know
two-plus hours on this okay guys if you
like this video give it a thumbs up let
me know in the comments down below who
you think I should make recreations of
in the future that's what we used to
kind of call these videos we creations
and clearly they're worth every moment
of it so leave a comment down below and
it's a bail notification so you know
what I upload videos because it's just
so inconsistent other than that I don't
know oh we made a mess it's Britney
Spears manager son Kenny I love her
sugar